[Musica]
la mia fascinazione per l'universo è
iniziata di fronte a un libro un libro
semplice di quelli per ragazzi pieno di
foto meravigliose e informazioni
dettagliatissime su pianeti stelle
galassie nebulose tutto quello che
affolla il nostro cielo
tra queste informazioni facevano la loro
bella figura numeri così grandi o così
piccoli che avevano bisogno di
tantissimi Zeri per essere
scritti ricordo di aver provato una
sensazione di vertigine nel cercare di
immaginare le cifre che mi venivano
snocciolate di fronte agli occhi zero
dopo Zero qualche anno più tardi gli
zeri furono sostituiti dagli esponenti
che permettevano di rendere maneggevoli
de numeri che non sarebbero ne ne anche
entrati nella pagina del
libro Poi fu il momento della mia prima
esperienza con un telescopio per la
prima volta di fronte ai miei occhi In
fondo all'oculare c'erano quegli oggetti
che avevano spinto al massimo la mia
immaginazione da
bambino mi sentivo immenso e minuscolo
effimero ed eterno
contemporaneamente la scala
dell'universo si estendeva di fronte a
me verso Mondi e tempi
incomprensibilmente grandi e sprofondava
sotto i miei piedi verso spazi e istanti
infinitesimi provai di nuovo quella vaga
sensazione di vertigine di Muto stupore
di fronte al
Cosmo vorrei provare stasera con voi ad
avventurarmi su questa scala Tuttavia è
facile perdere l'orientamento in questa
tempesta di Zeri ci serve quindi un
riferimento partiamo Quindi da un essere
umano si dice che per i fisici le mucche
siano sferiche perché questo semplifica
tantissimi conti Ecco un essere umano è
grande circa 1 m e non è sferico sarà
questo il nostro riferimento aggiungendo
uno zero alla dimensione di un essere
umano 10 m otteniamo un edificio mentre
un altro Zero ci porta alle dimensioni
di un quartiere e uno Zero Ancora alle
dimensioni di una città siamo saliti sul
terzo gradino della nostra scala delle
distanze e le cose sono già 1000 volte
più grandi 1 km nell'universo è la
dimensione di un asteroide in grado di
fare parecchi
danni il quarto gradino ci porta quindi
alle decine di chilometri gli Asteroidi
e le comente di queste dimensioni sono
ancora più dolorose Provate a chiederlo
ai dinosauri cosa ne pensano e sono
queste le dimensioni della gran parte
delle lune dei Giganti gassosi sono
probabilmente tutti Asteroidi catturati
i due gradini successivi della Scala il
quinto e il sesto ci portano proprio tra
le lune principali dei pianeti del
sistema solare dal piccolo mimante mimas
400 km il più piccolo oggetto sferico
del sistema solare al gigantesco
Ganimede oltre
5200 km di diametro più grande persino
del pianeta Mercurio Siamo sul Sesto
gradino e le cose sono già grandi come
pianeti i pianeti veri e propri si
occupano del settimo e dell'ottavo
gradino La Terra ha una dimensione di
circa 12.000 km Giove di 140.000
km finalmente sul nono gradino le cose
sono grandi come stelle miliardi di
volte più di un essere umano milioni di
chilometri le stelle poi nel corso della
loro esistenza cambiano evolvono alcune
di loro cambiano di colore temperatura e
dimensioni a volte possono raggiungere
diametri di miliardi di chilometri Siamo
sul 12o gradino In pratica tra la stella
più grande e la stella più piccola Ci
sono tre o quatt gradini la stessa
differenza che c'è tra le dimensioni di
un essere umano è una
città un passo ulteriore ci porta al 13o
gradino qui troviamo gli oggetti singoli
più grandi dell'universo i buchi neri
super massicci se prendessi il buco nero
al centro della galassia m87 e lo
mettessi al posto del Sole occuperebbe
l'intero volume del sistema solare
planetario più in alto sulla scala non
troviamo più oggetti singoli coerenti ma
gruppi di
cose le distanze tra le stelle sono
talmente grandi che per valicar Dobbiamo
saltare direttamente 3° e salire sul Seo
Qui finalmente incontriamo l'anno luce
la distanza percorsa dalla luce in un
anno gli astronomi La utilizzano per
rendere più maneggevoli gli abissi dello
spazio-tempo mediamente le stelle
distano tra di loro qualche anno luce
vanno a formare degli ammassi grandi
decine o centinaia di anni luce i più
grandi raggruppamenti di stelle
possibili sono le galassie la nostra ha
un diametro di di 100.000 anni luce 5
gradini in più siamo sul
vuno miliardi di miliardi di
chm una galassia rispetto a una stella è
molto più grande di una stella rispetto
a un essere
umano poi a loro volta anche le galassie
possono formare dei gruppi che possiamo
organizzare in ammassi e questi ammassi
li possiamo organizzare in super ammassi
centinaia di milioni di anni luce altri
Tre Gradini siamo arrivati al 24o e poi
basta perché c'è solo l'universo di più
grande l'intera dimensione dell'universo
A noi osservabile è di 93 miliardi di
anni luce un numero che scritto in metri
avrebbe bisogno di quasi 27 Zeri
miliardi di miliardi di
miliardi oltre la scala si perde nella
nebbia non sappiamo che cosa ci sia
oltre l'universo osservabile potrebbe
anche andare avanti
all'infinito visto che non possiamo
proseguire oltre torniamo indietro e
andiamo a vedere cosa c'è sotto i nostri
piedi
Beh il primo passo il primo gradino ci
porta alle dimensioni dei decimetri
quelle di un
gatto mentre il secondo gradino ci porta
ai centimetri la dimensione di una
farfalla e il terzo è quello dei
millimetri i granelli di sabbia i
successivi Tre Gradini sono lo
sterminato dominio delle cellule Alcune
grandi centinaia di micrometri come
l'ovulo umano altre grandi pochi
micrometri come il globulo rosso o i
batteri sotto nelle frazioni di
micrometro al settimo e ottavo gradino
troviamo i virus alcuni così piccoli da
essere grandi appena 20 nanomet vi
ricordate cosa c'era 8 gradini sopra di
noi il pianeta Giove vuol dire che un
essere umano per un virus è grande come
un
pianeta sul nono gradino troviamo il
mastro burattinaio della vita la
molecola di DNA ha una dimensione di 2
nanomet e una lunghezza che dipende da
quante informazioni contiene il DNA
umano è lungo circa 2 m e ciascuno di
voi custodisce 37 miliardi di copie di
questa
molecola oltre abbandoniamo il
territorio della chimica ed Entriamo nel
reame della quantistica perché sul Deo e
L'undicesimo gradino abbiamo gli atomi
il più piccolo di loro è l'atomo di Elio
ha un diametro di circa 56 picometri
millim miliardesimi di metro Anche se in
questo reame definire il concetto di
dimensioni è molto difficile poi c'è un
salto di 5 gradini tra il deo e il 15o
non c'è quasi niente un po' come era
capitato con l'anno luce quindi
scendiamo e andiamo a incontrare il
nucleo dell'atomo e i suoi costituenti
il protone e il neutrone questo salto
significa che il nucleo è 100.000 volte
più piccolo dell'atomo stesso è una
differenza confrontabile a quella che
c'era tra le stelle e gli spazi tra le
stelle salta fuori che la materia e
l'universo sono fatti praticamente di
spazio
vuoto scendere ancora ci porta
nuovamente a scontrarci con i confini
della nostra conoscenza del cosmo sul
18o gradino i miliardesimi di
miliardesimi di metro incontriamo la più
piccola particella per la quale abbia
ancora senso parlare di dimensioni il
Quark il Costituente fondamentale di
protoni e
neutroni Poi per quanto ne sappiamo
non c'è più nulla e la scala sprofonda
fino a raggiungere il 3o gradino la più
piccola distanza di spazio che abbia
senso nel nostro universo la lunghezza
di Plank la scala è terminata non ci
sono altri
gradini Il tempo invece è tutta un'altra
questione se la scala delle distanze ha
una sessantina di gradini quella del
tempo è semplicemente ineter
terminata il tempo ha iniziato a
scorrere circa 133,8 miliardi di anni fa
e continuerà a farlo per sempre l'età
dell'universo è una quantità di tempo
talmente inconcepibile da che facciamo
fatica a starci dietro Ma esiste un
trucco si chiama calendario cosmico è
stato inventato circa 50 anni fa dal più
grande comunicatore della Scienza
moderno Carl Sean l'idea di Sean era
molto semplice prendiamo l'intera storia
dell'universo e comprimi Amola in un
singolo anno di calendario l'inizio il
Big Bang è avvenuto alla mezzanotte del
primo gennaio oggi ora in questo momento
ci troviamo alla mezzanotte del 31
dicembre pronti a stappare lo spumante
Ecco in questa scala temporale un
secondo corrisponde a oltre 430 anni e
un giorno sono 37 milioni di anni nel
corso del mese di gennaio si sono
formate quasi tutte le delle galassie la
nostra è nata da qualche parte a
febbraio circa un miliardo di anni dopo
il big bang
e per i restanti mesi cosmici l'universo
è stato impegnato a formare stelle a
rotta di collo una dietro l'altra le
quali morendo hanno disseminato nello
spazio gli elementi chimici pesanti
prodotti dalla fusione
nucleare elementi da cui si possono fare
un sacco di cose interessanti E infatti
Ecco che a fine agosto 8 mesi
dall'inizio del tempo nasce il sistema
solare il mese di settembre è stato
molto intenso il 2 settembre si accende
il sole il 3 settembre Un grande impatto
crea la nostra Luna il 6 settembre la
formazione dei pianeti è completa il 14
settembre succede qualcosa di molto
particolare perché sulla vita sulla
terra compaiono le prime forme di vita
di cui abbiamo notizia forme di vita
anaerobiche perché per avere grandi
quantità di ossigeno nell'atmosfera del
del nostro pianeta dobbiamo attendere il
29 ottobre in quel momento si estinse il
999% delle forme di vita della terra Una
catastrofe i primi eucarioti compaiono
agli inizi di novembre e le prime forme
di vita pluricellulari a inizio dicembre
da qui le stelle le cose accelerano
vertiginosamente il 17 dicembre Nel mare
ci sono i pesci il 22 dicembre Gli
anfibi il 25 dicembre a Natale i
dinosauri conquistano il pianeta e alle
6:00 di mattina del 30 dicembre si
estinguono
l'intera evoluzione umana è concentrata
Nell'ultimo giorno il 31 dicembre Gli
ominidi sono comparsi alle 10 di sera la
nostra specie 8 minuti prima della
mezzanotte l'agricoltura 30 secondi
prima della mezzanotte la scienza 1
secondo fa lo sbarco sulla Luna un
decimo di secondo
fa calendario cosmico può anche essere
esteso nel futuro Nelso del prossimo
secondo ci giocheremo la partita con il
cambiamento climatico i cui effetti si
sentiranno per i prossimi un o du minuti
la biodiversità ince avrà bisogno di
molto più tempo per riprendersi 6 ore
cosmiche circa 10 milioni di
anni 10 milioni di anni nel futuro non è
troppo remoto Ma il cielo sarà già
completamente irriconoscibile a causa
del moto proprio delle stelle e della
morte delle giganti più luminose il 2
Gennaio è previsto un appuntamento molto
particolare perché la luna di Marte
phobos verrà fatta a pezzi dellaa
gravità del suo pianeta dotando Marte di
un bellissimo anello luminoso il 7
gennaio di questo nuovo anno cosmico
avremo compiuto un giro intero intorno
al centro della galassia e la terra avrà
ultimato la costruzione del nuovo
supercontinente il 16 gennaio ci sarà
L'ultima eclissi totale di luna a causa
del progressivo allontanamento del
nostro Sat satellite nel frattempo però
il sole sta
invecchiando Il primo febbraio sulla
terra si estingueranno tutte le forme di
vita vegetali complesse perché ormai fa
troppo caldo le forme di vita
unicellulari potrebbero durare un po' di
più fino al 15 marzo 2,8 miliardi di
anni nel futuro non di più nel corso del
mese di aprile si svolgerà la fusione
tra la galassia nostra e la galassia di
Andromeda e a luglio il sole diventerà
una gigante rossa morendo infine il 30
del
mese il futuro remoto è
inconcepibilmente lontano fra 120
miliardi di anni circa 9 anni cosmici
l'espansione accelerata del Cosmo avrà
allontanato le altre galassie al punto
che non ne potremo più vedere ci saranno
solo le stelle della Via Lattea e fra
80000 miliardi di anni circa 60 anni
cosmici anche le stelle più longeve
della Via Lattea cominceranno
gradualmente a spegnersi
il futuro remoto è qualcosa che diventa
rapidamente inconcepibile Abbiamo alcune
ipotesi eh Dobbiamo abbandonare il
calendario cosmico e tornare alla scala
delle potenze Perché fra 1000 miliardi
di anni 12 gradini nella nostra analogia
terminerà il gas per la formazione
stellare non non si potranno formare più
stelle l'universo l'avrà usato tutto
all'altezza del 13o e del 14o gradino
anche le stelle più longeve di tutte
moriranno e l'universo rimarrà popolato
solo da Oggetti degeneri nane Brune
buchi neri non ci sarà più
luce sul 15o gradino avviene la
smantellamento dinamico dei sistemi
planetari e sul ventesimo la
disgregazione delle galassie l'universo
Sarà popolato solamente da Oggetti
solitari Bui circondati da uno spazio
solipsistico vuoto e completamente
buio
ma il tempo continua a scorrere e il
tempo tutto divora se le nostre ipotesi
sono corrette all'altezza del 34o o 43o
gradino tutta la materia dell'universo
sarà decaduta in energia all'altezza del
67o
gradino i buchi neri di massa solare
evaporerà cosa che succederà ai buchi
neri super massicci al 92o
gradino oltre ancora diventa veramente
difficile orientarsi alcuni nostri
ipotesi prevedono eventi in un futuro
così remoto che potere per poter essere
trascritto avrebbe bisogno di un numero
di cifre tale da poter essere
rappresentato solo con una torre di
potenze un numero che non ci starebbe
nemmeno nell'intero Universo Figuratevi
nella pagina di un
libro nell'altra direzione della Scala
temporale invece possiamo scendere
rendendo gli istanti temporali sempre
più piccoli fino a renderli così piccoli
che nuovamente perdono di significato si
parla di intervalli temporali inferiori
a un decimilionesimo di miliardesimo di
miliardesimo di miliardesimo di
miliardesimo Di secondo sono 43 Zeri
dopo la virgola e il cosiddetto tempo di
Plank tempi più piccoli di questo non
hanno
significato gira un po' la testa a me
[Applauso]
sì È questa la sensazione che provai
anni fa e non credo che sarò mai in
grado di abituarmi Nessuno può farlo ma
è da questa sensazione che nasce la
scienza e da questo bisogno di dipanare
La matassa dell'ignoto che giunge all
scoperta la cosa incredibile è che tutto
questo nella nostra testa ci sta in
qualche modo lo riusciamo a concepire a
maneggiare quasi con disinvoltura siamo
minuscoli rispetto alle scale spaziali
temporali dell'universo eppure siamo
immensi qua
dentro Non dimenticate mai il potere
della vostra immaginazione perché è lei
la forza creatrice dietro all'umanità a
volte per scatenarla basta pochissimo
come un libro pieno di immagini di
pianeti nelle mani di un ragazzino
curioso
[Applauso]
Grazie
l